Vernünftig oder zuckersüß
– eine von tausend kleinen Entscheidungen,
die wir alle täglich treffen.
Warum entscheiden wir wie?
Und: Lassen wir uns auch ohne
Verbote irgendwie lenken?
Vielleicht durch einen kleinen
Stups Richtung Vernunft?
Kathrin Loer ist Sozialwissenschaftlerin.
Sie erforscht, was die Entscheidungen
von Menschen beeinflusst.
Unser Treffpunkt:
die Mensa der Uni Osnabrück.
Hier ist nichts Zufall.
Die Salatbar dominiert den Raum.
Denn die Studenten sollen
sich gesünder ernähren.
Das ist die Idee dabei, dass Salat sehr
ansprechend dargestellt wird.
Und natürlich hab ich auch
alle anderen Optionen,
und die sind praktisch jetzt im
Moment in meinem Rücken.
Ja. Also der Fokus soll auf Salat liegen.
Ja. Also, das wäre jetzt auch vielleicht …
Für ’ne Schulmensa wäre das ’ne gute
... ’n gutes Arrangement.
Natürlich können die Studenten
trotzdem noch Fritten essen
– und einiges Ungesunde mehr.
Aber der Appetit auf Salat
ist größer geworden.
Denn der Aufbau der Mensa und
die Anordnung des Essens
lenkt die Entscheidungen der Studenten.
„Nudging“ heißt diese Technik.
Also „Nudging“ heißt erst mal „Stupsen“,
und hinter diesem Begriff,
diesem englischsprachigen Begriff,
versammelt sich ’ne ganze Zahl
von verschiedenen Techniken,
die sich auf eine sogenannte
Entscheidungsarchitektur beziehen.
Das ist ... hört sich komplizierter an, als es ist.
Also, das ist im Grunde die Welt,
in der wir leben
und wie sie gebaut ist, wie sie gestaltet ist.
Und diese Nudging-Techniken,
die führen dazu,
dass man sich in einer bestimmten Weise
möglicherweise verhält oder
eben nicht verhält.
Zweites Beispiel: Nudging-Techniken, um
Ressourcen zu schonen.
Wie viel Papier jemand verbraucht,
hängt ganz entscheidend von diesem kleinen
Haken ab: beidseitig drucken.
Und ob – zumindest meistens – beidseitig
gedruckt wird oder nicht,
das hängt von den Werkseinstellungen ab,
mit denen der Drucker geliefert wird.
Das ist praktisch der Bau einer
Entscheidungsarchitektur, der darauf abzielt,
dass die Menschen sich in einer
bestimmten Weise verhalten.
Es ist typischerweise so, dass Menschen dem
folgen, was ihnen praktisch angeboten wird
oder wie es voreingestellt ist.
Auch gerade bei so ganz vielen
ritualisierten Dingen
ist die Voreinstellung das Entscheidende
dafür, wie sich Menschen verhalten. Ja.
Ein guter Grund übrigens auch mal
in die Voreinstellungen zum
Datenschutz zu gucken.
Bisher werden die Standards dort
von Google und Co gesetzt
– Konzernen also, die Interesse
haben an möglichst vielen Daten.
Auch das ist eine Nudging-Technik:
„Disclosure“, also Offenlegung,
wie die anderen sich verhalten.
Denn die meisten Menschen
wollen sich vergleichen und dazugehören.
Konkret heißt das: Wer mit der
Stromrechnung auch die Durchschnittswerte
seiner Region und damit
seiner Nachbarn erfährt,
ist eher geneigt, Energie zu sparen.
Viele Menschen, bei denen funktioniert das.
Sie möchten ja zu ’ner Gruppe dazugehören.
Das sehen wir ja in anderen Bereichen
der sozialen Medien auch sehr stark.
Und auf dieses ... auf diesen
Mechanismus setzt man dabei.
Wer „nudgt“, versucht, Entscheidungen
von Menschen zu beeinflussen,
genau wie Firmen das mit
Marketing und Werbung tun.
Das funktioniert aber auch
bei dieser Freizeitsportgruppe:
Hartes Training zweimal die Woche und
fast immer sind alle dabei. Wie geht das?
Sie haben im Voraus bezahlt.
Und das ist nicht ihre einzige Motivation.
Das ist ’ne Mischung von drei Nudges.
Im Grunde ist es einmal
die Selbstbindung ganz am Anfang,
sich für einen überschaubaren
Zeitraum zu binden.
In diesem Fall sind das hier neun
Wochen. Das ist der erste Nudge.
Dann gibt es sogenannte „Reminder“,
also Erinnerungen, die persönlich kommen,
dass man zum Training geht, wenn man’s
vielleicht vergessen hat oder nicht ...
noch nicht in der Stimmung war.
Das Dritte ist
auch so ’ne Form von „Social Norms“,
also das Eingebundensein
in so ’nen sozialen Kontext. Und diese
drei Nudges zusammen funktionieren hier.
Nudges, der kleine Stupser
Richtung gute Vorsätze:
Klappt oft, aber nicht immer
und nicht bei jedem.